Шановні колеги найпопулярніші в Україні
політик Боріс Джонсон дуже точно сказав
формулу сильної держави це сильний
незалежний парламент і незалежні медіа
так ось цією постановою вбивається і
парламентаризм і свобода слова це про те
як дискредитувати роботу парламенту і
знецінити роботу кожного народного
депутата а парламенту взагалі втратити
свою суб'єктність Ми хочемо подякувати
250 депутатам слух народу які не
підписали цю ганьбу за виключенням
одного штрих-брехера і насправді це
постанова про те як не висвітлювати
роботу Верховної Ради України при тому
на роботу телеканалу рада виділяється
500 мільйонів гривень але цією
постановою зараз там пропонують не
показувати не просто трансляція а навіть
у запису наше з вами прийняття законів
обговорення і позиція ви знаєте Я уважно
прочитала біографію автора цієї
постанови він родом з Маріуполя так от
по цій постанові люди які виїхали з
Маріуполя ніколи не почують позиції
спільної парламенту по необхідності
звільнення захисників азовсталії по цій
постанові ніколи не почують жителі
Маріуполя що ми боремося за них і
Закликаємо не давати візи росіянам по
цій постанові жителі Маріуполя не
почують про те що ми з вами намагаємося
захистити українську армію і надати їй
всі необхідні повноваження і насправді
навіть призи для Верховної Ради
побоялися підписати цю ганьбу спущену з
офісу президента і Міністерства цензури
сьогодні блок телеканалу рада Все весь
ранок показував позаштатних радників
офісу президента заступників глави офісу
президента там немає Тільки політиків
немає депутатів немає парламенту і ми не
дозволимо дискредитувати з не зробити І
взагалі парламенту втратити суб'єктність
цю Постанову треба Ви дуже правильно не
підписали її зараз